Women are calling you out for being
serial cheaters, abusers, stalkers,
general creeps, and you respond by
posting their nudes.
>> She's basically justifying the app.
She's basically saying, "Oh, cuz there
was a couple of men or let's let's
suppose one or two% of the men on the
app that they did a same version of only
for men's were posting nudes." And she
went and just labeled all the men in
there are doing that. That's the reason
why she's justifying why the tea app
exists.
Islam is raising funds to establish a
masjid and community center in Norway
and they urgently need your support.
This donation will be a for you because
every person that comes a step closer to
Allah through your donation, you will in
be reaping the reward. Click the link
and donate what you can.
Brothers and sisters and dear friends,
the western woman is going absolutely
berserk. Why? Because they are in the
dating world. They are the gatekeepers
of sex and that is something precious.
Allah subhanaa tala has created women in
a very specific way and because they
have no guidance because they don't have
Allah subhanaa tala in their life they
are in turmoil why because they are
dating men that is dating multiple of
them together not only that they are
getting false promises being used
cheated on um some of them are being
abused because you are dating these men
that you don't know about and in the
dating world as a as a non-Muslim it's
you know whatever you want to do you
know there's one man stands you have sex
with absolute strangers can you imagine
sharing your private parts intimately
with someone that you don't even know.
Here's videos that we're going to watch
and we're going to tell you a bit about
the TA app. Where is the T- app? The T
app is officially known as tea dating
advice. Is a mobile phone application
that allows women to post personal data
about men they are interested in or are
currently dating. The app has been
subject to substantial controversy for
both its functions and it exposure of
user data because it's been leaked.
72,000 women's information has been
leaked with 13,000 images with driver
license details to what they weigh. Yes,
I'm talking about what they weigh.
Brothers and sisters, all information
has been leaked. Here's some videos that
we're going to watch inshallah. And I
want to tell Muslim women that's
watching this or non-Muslim women that
are watching this that you need Islam
because in Islam there is no dating.
There is no hey, you know, get to know
one another whatever is for that matter
because men will take advantage of you.
This doesn't mean women are stupid or
dumb or vulnerable or naive. No, of
course it's vulnerability to women.
That's the reason why God Almighty has
given certain certain protocols to
protect you. But in Islam, we have
something called putting our trust in
Allah and knowing that he knows who's
best for us. Let's watch the first video
inshallah and see what we can dissect.
>> There is a new king of the app store
free chart. It is tea dating advice
helping women date safe. They basically
productize the groups on Facebook, the
are we dating the same guy groups. And
so this is acts as a layer over a bunch
of different dating apps where women can
effectively review, add comments, leave
Yelp style reviews for the men uh that
they are going on dates with. Okay.
Firstly, as you can see, this just
explained that manager explained in a
brief what the app is about, which I've
told you about. Uh and one thing you
need to understand though, not many
people would speak good of their exes.
they would it's very very hard to find
someone genuine and especially with
women sometimes they are scorned and you
know uh they are with men and whatever
it is for that matter and they don't
like them when it ends on most of the
times marriages or someone that you're
dating ends nasty okay so how do you
expect a group of women to come together
which we know a woman likes to speak
more than men and they are sharing this
experience etc and to them anything can
be like oh he's a narcissist he's this
is that uh which women tend to use very
loosely how do you expect a group of
come together and say, "Oh, yeah, that
guy. Yeah, he's good. Yeah, I do." You
really think a woman is going to
recommend her ex to another woman? Do
you really think a woman is going to be,
"Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, go. He was such a
nice guy. Yeah, you know, we broke up,
etc., but he's a nice guy. Go date him."
I don't think the idea is good because
you're looking for a solution, but the
solution isn't Islam. Yes, prevention is
better than cure, which I'm going to
come to later. Here's the second video,
inshallah. Let's see what this woman had
to say.
>> Women are harassing men online in a new
app. And this app called the T is a
women's only app where you can upload
photos and information and screenshots
of men that you might be dating or maybe
you just swiped on, you know, their
dating profile. Maybe you've just met
him. You can post photos of him or
screenshots of his dating profile in
order to get the tea on him from other
women. And all hell has broken loose on
social media. Understandably so because
men are concerned about their privacy,
concerned with what accusations or lies
or even exaggerations could be, you
know, slo about them online with no
consent, with no idea that it is
actually happening and no ability to
defend themselves whatsoever. They
aren't even allowed on the app. Imagine
if men had an app like this. If men were
online posting photos of women ripping
their appearances to shreds, saying this
is how many men she slept with, all hell
would break loose. Women would be losing
their mind.
>> Do not forget to download the Salah Pro
app, guys. It's a free app, free ads,
free kfinder, salah time, salah
reminders. You can book a salah
instructor, order a guided prayer mat,
find your local salah hub, watch videos
on how to pray salah. The app is
absolutely free on Android, iOS. Till
next time.
>> Is she wrong? Please guys, I mean, let's
let's be clear. Is she wrong? If we was
to start an app and men will come in and
like listen. Number one, in Islam,
slander is very severe, especially
towards a woman. For those who come and
say Islam is misogynistic. No,
especially the hadith narrations of the
prophet Muhammad peace be upon mention
seven major sins. One of those major
sins is what? Slander against a chased
woman. So imagine an apps being made.
There will be hell breaking loose, bro.
Bro, there'll be there'll be chaos.
they'll be it'll be felt 12.7 on the
RTER scale everywhere around the world.
But when women do it, it's it's it's
fine. Why? Because the core of the
problem is something deeper which I'm
going to come to and I'm going to watch
the final video and then we're going to
come to what is the solution in. This
video is of a hijabi sister. I want to
see what she had to say as a Muslim
perspective on it. Um someone who does
pro Palestinian stuff I follow on
Instagram. She does pro Palestinian
stuff. But let's see what she had to say
cuz she had her two pens piece on this
app.
>> Okay, this is absolutely insane
to me. The tea app got men so mad that
they've been threatening to drop their
own version of the girls. And one of
those apps, I'm sure it'll be one of
many, was already launched and shut down
within 24 hours because men kept posting
women's nudes. Like, y'all think I'm
playing with you. This is from the
Teaborn app. App is down until everyone
learns how to behave. If you're posting
nudes, I will be posting your face.
These men are just like consistently
proving why the tea app was created in
the first place. Like honestly, I really
I can't believe this. Women are calling
you out for being serial cheaters,
abusers, stalkers, general creeps, and
you respond by posting their nudes.
You are everything that they're saying
that you are. I don't understand how you
don't see that. This app is like
Dearborn specific, too, I'm pretty sure.
So like these are Muslim men posting
nude pictures of Muslim women. Like have
some
>> Okay, firstly again I'm I'm a bit taken
aback in the sense where because she's
basically justifying the app. She's
basically saying oh cuz there was a
couple of men or let's let's suppose one
or two% of the men on the app that they
did a uh same version of only for men's
were posting nudes. And she went and
just labeled all the men in there are
doing that. That's the reason why she's
justifying why the tea app exists. And
it's the same problem. And then she went
towards the end. I'm just going to
construct criticism towards the end
saying that oh she's not even saying for
sure. She's saying oh it's it's around
the Mishkan area there's a lot of big
Muslim population there. Therefore she's
concluding yes uh that there has to be a
correlation that um therefore that means
Muslim men are most likely post
basically saying there were men there
posting nudes of women. This app is
based in Michigan as well. Also people
downloaded in Michigan. Michigan is
populated by Muslims. Therefore, it
concludes that Muslim men are posting
news of Muslim women. You I'm I'm so
sorry. You've just made that assertion.
You've just made that uh thing up there.
There's no evidence to it, sister. And
um you and not only that, you're
actually justifying what they're doing.
So, are you okay? So, you're basically
saying because of this, that's why women
have a right to do that. Well, the
solution is very simple. You are a
Muslim woman. Uh my dear sister, I just
adise you to everybody for that matter.
In Islam, we believe in something and
Islam has protocols. Islam believes in
prevention is better than cure. We do
not do dating in Islam. If you were not
to do dating in Islam, you Muslim women
and non-Muslim women, they should know
better. Non-Muslim women, if you
followed Islam, you will not have this
problem. You will not have the problem
of going on dates with random men. You
don't know who they are. Nothing about
them. And they give you some false
promises. Say some words you want, they
want to hear, and whatever it is for
that matter. And then next thing you
know, you like them, sleep with them
that night or a week later or two weeks
later or a month later or three months
later or four months later. and then
afterwards you he decides or you find
out he's an F boy whatever it is for
that matter he leaves you and then you
are broken you're shattered etc you need
to understand women are the gatekeepers
of sex therefore if you something that
is valuable something that is valuable
why is something valuable because it is
rare it is rare if you give that to
everybody
the value doesn't stay there yes it
depreciates so therefore you need to
understand men are going to be men this
doesn't excuse them because in Islam The
punishment for a man and a woman is the
same. If a adultery happens, sex outside
of marriage, there's a capital
punishment. The punishment is the same
in Islam. It doesn't say one rule for
men, one rule for woman. No, but if you
did that, you will understand that it
protects you. I'll give you a fine
example of myself when I was getting to
know my wife for marriage. I couldn't go
on dates. There was no dates, you know,
let's just go on casual dates, let's go
out, etc. No, because God almighty knows
the prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
said, "When a man and a woman is alone,
the third is Satan." Meaning what? A man
and a woman are created with this strong
attraction to one another. So what do
you think is going to happen when you're
alone? Something's going to happen. So
therefore, I could get to know my wife
for marriage with a chaperone. Somebody
had to be there. Not where we are
sitting exactly, but there was someone
there who was keeping an eye. Why? It's
to protect her and it's to protect me.
So number one, number two, and number
two when it comes to that, if I am happy
with the marriage, number one, before
all of that, I speak to the father. Why?
You talk about the patriarchy,
patriarchy, patriarchy. Another man
takes another man to account with all
due respect. Okay? another man takes
another man's account because a man
knows a man. So therefore, that is the
second protocol that protects you.
Number three, my wife will ask for a
dowy. That is her right. Why? In case
I'm an deadbeat dad, decide to
disappear, she has money, finances that
she can fall back on. Not only that, it
also as a man shows me what? If I'm
serious about her or if I don't like
her, I don't want to pay the dowy,
whichever month it is. It it's her
protection. Number four, I have to do a
wedding. Yes. not something extravagant
but a wedding and tell the people that
I've married her we're married so people
know there's no chitchat gossiping
happening and then on not only that I
have responsibilities and duties what
that means is the following I have so
many protocols that Islam has given me
to go through that gives the right of my
wife to not be abused and used think
about that guys Islam has got protocols
to protect the woman and also protect
the man against gold diggers because if
she's a gold digger the diary that he
gave he would take that back. So there's
protocols to protect both's hearts and
do it in a way that God Almighty has
objectively decided. Now we need to
abide by those laws. Yes. What happens
is chaos because you're attaching
yourself to a human being. Yes. There's
heartbreak. There's people who kill
theirel out of heartbreak. You're
meeting people dating and guess what?
Dating doesn't work. Dating doesn't
work. And then what's happen is
destroying yourself. Especially affects
a woman. Studies show that a woman who
has more than three or four sexual
partners, her likelihood of having a
successful marriage, successful marriage
goes from 80% to 20%. Okay? And then not
only that, you've got men who are also
having all these women. Now, he's going
to be comparing his wife to all the
other women that he have and he's not
going to be happy. And there's so much
other illnesses. And the main illness is
what? The T app, which is what? Let's
come together and find a solution. God
almighty, Allah has given you that
solution from the get-go to protect
yourself. And if you don't do that, you
make man-made ideas or apps or laws, and
then you put that together, backfires,
doesn't work. And guess what? It makes
it worse because why you're going there
and talking about men, you're actually
slandering them because there might be
men that are innocent there, but there's
a woman who's excell upset for whatever
reason. Yes. And then what happens is
talks bad of him and he's slandered. And
now men do the opposite. And the cycle
continues. Alhamdulillah for Islam. You
know why? Cuz we have trust in God. We
have relation with God. We communicate
with God. before I met my wife is takar
is takar is what asking God almighty if
that woman is good for me or if I'm good
for her make it happen if it's not move
away from me and move me away from her
we make duas we have why because we
trust the due process that god has given
me and we have the divine connection
with god almighty that we ask him for
guidance and that is where successful
true marriages happen and truly prosper
so for the tea app you can carry on
drinking that tea because in Islam
alhamdulillah we have laws and
legislation that has been put in place
to protect my heart, my wife's heart and
that unit together. The generations to
come of our children are also protected
and the western world is in absolute
collapse of morality and everyone is
suffering at the consequences and some
even they go and take their lives.
Alhamdulillah for Islam. You can keep
your tea app join Islam and find true
freedom from the shackles of the worldly
life and to your creator. Till next
time.